bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver en compagnie de mickey la meuf
bonjour michael semaine noire pour le
gouvernement c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire il ya eu d'abord le texte sur le
logement social a retoqué par le conseil
constitutionnel pour cause de procédure
législative mal respectée l'annoncé a
été faite non par les sages mais par
jean marc ayrault court circuiter le
conseil constitutionnel amateurisme à
cri l'opposition
les sénateurs s'y sont mis aussi cette
semaine pour assombrir la semaine du
gouvernement les a déclarées
irrecevables au texte sur la
tarification de l'énergie lors de
l'examen en commission ce sont les
communistes alliés supposer qu'ils ont
déposé la motion ambiance garantie mardi
prochain dans l'hémicycle lors de
l'examen du texte
enfin l'ump qui ne te cus réjouir des
couacs de la majorité a connu cette
semaine son duel au sommet débat
télévisé copé fillon qui en est sorti
gagnant
on essaiera de répondre à la question
est avec nous pour commenter et toute
cette actualité et chantal jouanno
bonjour bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions alors les téléspectateurs des
chaînes parlementaires vous connaissent
très bien
d'une part parce que vous avez été
ministre sous le gouvernement de
françois fillon ministre des sports
ministre est également de l'écologie
puis vous avez été élue sénatrice
il y a un petit peu plus d'un an donc on
vous connaît aussi depuis quelques jours
parce que vous avez fait le buzz entre
guillemets vous avez décidé de quitter
l'ump pour rejoindre le parti de jean
louis borloo lui dit on va en parler en
quelques secondes mais je vous propose
d'écouter certains de vos collègues qui
commentent votre transfert elle a
considéré qu'elle était beaucoup mieux
qu'elle pourrait beaucoup mieux
s'exprimer en venant lui pays elle a
fait ce choix
alors évidemment je sais que et une
passe et moi même j'étais son adversaire
politique aux sénatoriales puisque
c'était ma concurrente je vais même pris
un siège mais vous savez la politique
c'est ça va passer sur ce genre de
choses on est toujours déçu quand on
fait confiance à une candidate et que on
voit sa confiance trahie par cette
candidate elle doit ses mandats à
l'engagement derrière
des militants et des adhérents et des
électeurs de l'ump qui ont voté pour
elle
essentiellement parce qu'elle était à la
tête d'une liste ump elle change de
parti et donc elle doit remettre ses
mandats la disposition du parti qui l'a
fait élire
madame janot a fait un choix personnel
elle est très engagée sur les questions
de l'environnement sur les questions de
société
elle a souhaité rejoindre les centristes
je comprends compte tenu de ces camps en
gage nom de ses convictions
cette démarche pour ma part je partage
pleinement ses engagements mais j'essaye
de défendre les idées centristes au sein
même de l'ump
vous avez entendu fabienne keller elle
vous comprends même temps elle dit moi
j'ai décidé de rester à bord de l'ump à
l'intérieur pour me battrai pas quitter
le navire
vous avez quitté ma bien non parce que
je suis pas parti à gauche
enfin il ya des idées c'est que c'est un
grand un grand classique je ne serai
plus jamais allé à lutter ici
l'idée n'était pas dans une coalition
très clair avec avec l'ump ce qui
n'était pas aussi évident auparavant
avec la myriade de partis ni centriste
donc on est quand même dans un parti en
coalition est dans un parti qui demain
avec l'ump a des gros défis à relever
notamment sur les élections
intermédiaires déçu vous alliez la
remettre vous remettre vos mandats c'est
assez traverse pas l'esprit
c'est un grand classique cette 7e
demande d'ailleurs qui m'est très
particulière puisqu'il ya plusieurs
autres personnes qu'on fait qui ont
aussi changé de parti sans qu'on
n'aurait jamais demandé pour autant le
vrai sujet aujourd'hui à mon avis c'est
plutôt de se dire que l'ump ayant est
vraiment là je critique pas le choix
n'ayant plus ces sujets dans son coeur
de programme ni l'écologie ni l'europe
dans une vision fédéraliste et que lui
dit elle aujourd'hui se définit sur ces
sujets c'était plus cohérent d'être en
positif dans une démarche dans un parti
qui se dit allié de l'ump qu'être
parfois est trop souvent en dissidence
interne car c'est plus confortable
d'ailleurs d'être en dissidence interne
parce que vous faîtes le buzz médiatique
mais c'est pas extrêmement respectueux
ni des électeurs ni de la politique en
général fillon quand même que vous
souteniez ouvertement 1,10 pour qu'elle
soit élue au sénat sous l'étiquette ump
il a fallu à l'époque sous de sacrifier
d'autres personnalités de talents il
faut pas redonner ce siège à ses
personnages étaient finalement oui enfin
enfant gâté si vous savez s'il y avait
vraiment eu cette attitude d'enfant gâté
je ne serais pas parti à lui dit je
n'aurais pas fait ce pari c'est beaucoup
plus confortable de rester dans un grand
parti et de ne pas faire le pari de la
nouveauté de ne pas faire de ne pas dire
très clairement écouter voilà il manque
quelque chose
aujourd'hui dans le paysage politique et
je pense que c'est pas dans l'ue
aujourd'hui c'est plus l'ump de 2007
masse et on a marqué moi je suis arrivé
avec nicolas sarkozy comme sarkozyste
parce que ils défendent est
effectivement un projet qui est l âge
avec des sujets d'ouverture aujourd'hui
effectivement le hand et moi en plus
pour qu'on comprenne bien quel moment
précisément ces faits la voiture de
votre esprit il ya quelque chose ça
déclenche et envoyée il ya un élément
déception non il ya un élément très
simple vous saviez vous pour parler de
déception
rien à dire il ya un élément très simple
c'est que au fur et à mesure les sujets
ont disparu dans la campagne pour la
future présidence de l'ump j'ai
interpellé les deux candidats sur ces
sujets en leur disant vous pouvez pas
parler de croissance si vous ne parlez
pas d'énergie si vous parlez pas de
transition énergétique c'est impossible
a aucune croissance historique qui s'est
fait avec moins d'énergie
donc vous devez en parler ils n'ont pas
répondu mais du tout germe même pas fait
l'effort de dire oui on verra ce sujet
ultérieurement parce qu'aujourd'hui on
est
on est en campagne interne donc là ça a
été tout ça est effectivement assez
progressif mais surtout le changement
c'est clairement quand jean louis borloo
a dit aujourd'hui on lance lui d i en
coalition
et c'est pour moi le principal on est
partenaire donc cessons à travers moi de
dire que l'ump élu d y sont des partis
qui seraient en compétition en
concurrence en opposition sur à paris
très honnêtement on ferait mieux de
concentrer son énergie sur un nouveau
projet alternatif à celui de monsieur
delanoë que madame jourdain mots non
mais je ne dis ça à mes à mes amis de
paris jade est aujourd'hui toujours
maintenant que vous êtes pas lui dès
aujourd'hui j'ai un vrai défi à lui d
ici mon premier pari c'est de construire
l'écologie donc de paris non non je n'ai
pas dit que c'était de côté j'ai dit que
pour l'instant c'est ma première
priorité on verra on verra après je dis
juste à mes amis que on pourra pas y
aller séparément on pourra pas y aller
dans la division on pourra pas continuer
sur cette vision selon laquelle quand on
va à lui dit on va chez l'ennemi non on
va pas chez l'ennemi quand on va à lui
dit on a perdu toute une partie de
l'électorat qui repose sur les
professions intellectuelles sur un
électorat écologie sur injecter leur
électorat par des centristes on doit
travailler cet électorat on doit
redynamiser notre projet sur cet
électorat donc aujourd'hui navy la
priorité c'est plutôt de construire ce
n'est pas de détruire al et chantal
jouanno va dérouiller ensemble fil de la
semaine c'est le principe de l'émission
et lundi bien ne parle que d'un certain
louis gallois
pas moins de dix huit ministres
convoqués à matignon par jean marc
ayrault pour participer à une grande
réunion sur la compétitivité le
gouvernement veut montrer qu'il est
mobilisé sur ce sujet en attendant le
rapport de louis gallois rapport qui
sera remis le 5 novembre prochain
compte-rendu jérôme rabhi réunion au
sommet pour reprendre en main le dossier
compétitivité 18 ministres convoqué la
presse conviée le tout pour prouver que
le gouvernement considère comme
prioritaire ce dossier après les
premières fuites sur le rapport gallois
qui préconiserait une hausse de la tva
et de la csg pour baisser les charges
sur le travail
le gouvernement a voulu montrer qu'au
final c'est lui qui trancherait ce
rapport gallois d'un rapport qui est de
contribution extrêmement importante mais
il est logique aussi que de notre côté
les administrations les ministères nous
menions notre propre démarche pour être
prêt si la question du coût du travail
est centrale il faut aussi évoquer
d'autres sujets comme l'innovation la
recherche pour parler compétitivité
c'est ce qui a été au coeur des
discussions aujourd'hui la question du
coût ne sera l aborder que vendredi lors
d'une nouvelle réunion
mais pour l'opposition c'est déjà un
véritable camouflet à la demande un
grand patron de gauche d'expertisé
d'auditionner de faire des propositions
et au bout de trois mois il propose ce
que finalement nicolas sarkozy avait
proposé à sa campagne des
présidentielles visiblement vu les
premières réactions aux premières pistes
de louis gallois
on peut s'inquiéter pas vraiment enterré
mais largement minimisé le rapport
gallois au complet est toujours attendu
pour le 5 novembre prochain un séminaire
gouvernemental est prévue dès le
lendemain pour rendre les premiers
arbitrages du gouvernement alors chantal
jouanno françois hollande l'a annoncé il
n'y aura pas un choc de compétitivité
mais impact déjà est ce qu'il ya une
différence
et est ce que c'est une erreur ou pas
mais c'est tout ça c'est une faute
politique lourde vraiment pas ce que je
comprends pas cet autisme terra nova la
cour des comptes
aujourd'hui le gallois disent tous
sensibilité socialiste sensibilité
socialiste en cour des comptes présidée
par monsieur migaud vous savez tous la
même chose il y a un problème de
compétitivité avec
d'abord une compétitivité coût et puis
une compétitivité hors cour les deux
sujets vraiment et les deux sujets
doivent être étaient ils disent tous la
même chose on est plus en campagne
électorale
ils ont pu besoin de jouer à ça la
première chose qu'ils ont fait c'est de
défaire la tva dite sociale
compétitivité appelez la comme vous
laisser paraître de toute façon qui
était joseph une idée d'ailleurs porté
par jean arthuis parle udi etc est une
bonne idée voilà
point à la ligne bon aujourd'hui il
ferme toutes les portes
perdre toutes les portes mais pour des
raisons purement politiques sauf que
c'est grave
cette idée de bach pour dire on va
prendre notre temps mais l'économie elle
n'a pas de temps prendre vous regardez
ce qui se passe en espagne 25 % de
chômage
enfin je trouve que aujourd'hui
prétendre à dire que finalement il n'y
aura pas de décision parce que c'est une
décision positive mais toutes les
parades aux décisions économies qu'ils
entendent éventuellement mais on frappe
à la tva
ils ont annoncé récemment il y aura pas
de hausse de la csg ni cette année ni
les années suivantes
ils ont fermé toutes les portes qu'est
ce qu'ils font et surtout que la csg est
pas plus juste entre guillemets que la
tva à la tva il est beaucoup plus juste
elle pèse pas sur les produits de base
elle pèse pas sur les produits de passe
la csn bay sur tout le monde donc c'est
je trouve qu'on n'est plus en campagne
voilà ils ont droit maintenant de se
dire on est plus en campagne et
travailler pour l'intérêt de la cour la
même problématique aux de la hausse de
la csg ou la tva ça veut dire aussi
baisse du pouvoir d'achat
on guettera un air de mal à s'orienter
aussi savent que voilà on peut juste
regarder ce qui a été voté au mois de
juillet le plfss le plf tout n'est qu'un
pur tout n'est qu'un pot alors
l'argument du pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui honnêtement non mais c'est
grave parce que franchement il ya des
emplois derrière et aujourd'hui il y
aura pas de justice y aura pas de
protection sociale s'il ya pas de
croissance et il n'y a pas d'emploi
c'est impossible
ça s'est jamais vu dans l'histoire
chantal jouanno va passer au mardi puis
on va rester un petit peu sur le même
thème puisque devinez quoi on parle
encore de louis gallois
et cette fois c'est dans l'hémicycle que
revient le futur rapport gallois
puisqu'il est toujours pas sorti a
accusé de vouloir enterrer le rapport
jean marc ayrault s'en prend à
l'opposition
effet garanti ces uvres là qui nous
raconte la séance la question venait de
sa majorité
la réponse semblait taillé pour
l'opposition j'ai demandé à monsieur
louis gallois
un rapport en effet mais qui ne sera pas
un rapport de plus mais qui sera une
contribution à la décision et à l'action
dans l'hémicycle une mise au point de
jean marc ayrault sur le rapport gallois
et dans le chahut général mais on aurait
l'impression à droite que vous souhaiter
l'échec de la france
moi je souhaite un succès de l'app le
départ de nombreux députés ump moi je ne
vais pas accepter ni aucun de mes amis
députés
on explique que nous ne travaillons pas
pour l'intérêt de la france un incident
de quelques minutes à peine après une
empoignade de plusieurs jours
mandaté par françois hollande pour
effectuer ses recommandations en matière
de compétitivité des entreprises
françaises
l'ancien patron de eads pourrait
proposer des mesures comme
l'augmentation de la tva une
recommandation non confirmées du rapport
très loin en tout cas de la feuille de
route du gouvernement
et puis quelques jours on sent tourner
le vent pourquoi est pas parce qu on
pressent que ce qui a dans rapport
gallois pourtant un patron gauche
quelqu'un qui a été directeur de cabinet
deux fois de jean pierre chevènement
dont une fois au ministère de
l'industrie quelqu'un qui connaît son
sujet on sent que ce qu'il ya dedans va
gêner au revirement pour l'opposition
cohérence pour la majorité qui se défend
de toute remise en cause de l'utilité du
rapport
il faut forcément regarder attentivement
le rapport et au groupe nous
l'occasion dé clora pour gallois sera
déposée de travail et de mettre en place
un groupe de travail spécifique à
l'assemblée objet de toutes les
polémiques les conclusions réel du
rapport gallois ne seront rendus publics
que le 5 novembre et seront aussitôt
suivi assure la majorité d'une réunion
interministérielle sur les chantiers
prioritaires à mettre en oeuvre
bon chantal jouanno vous avez été vous
même sur les bandes ministre un petit
peu un effet de manche quand même ce
départ qui était sûrement sur mon
programme et les socialistes faisaient
la même chose en leur temps il ya quand
même c'est une accusation grave c'est
quand même une accusation grave de dire
à l'opposition qu'elle se préoccupe pas
de l'avenir de la france alors même que
l'opposition depuis des mois et des mois
et des mois et notamment pendant la
campagne politique d'ici peu il ya un
problème de compétitivité qui a été nié
pendant la campagne
donc non c'est grave parce que regarder
tous les pays qui ont surmonté la crise
l'allemagne en premier la suède quand
ils ont fait leur fond qui est très très
longtemps
ça se fait dans l'union ça se fait dans
la coalition donc honnêtement dire par
là je me faire l'avocat du premier
ministre est ce qu'il n'a pas voulu dire
par là qu'il fallait justement un
consensus et que l'on peut pas dire qui
aujourd'hui ils le cherchent vraiment
enfin c'est plutôt au contraire toujours
des des attaques non c'est l'idée
d'enterrer le rapport l'idée dit on va
faire un groupe de travail donc on va
encore prendre des mois
c'est catastrophique c'est
catastrophique pour la france il n'y a
eu que des mauvaises nouvelles encore
cette semaine en termes de plans sociaux
de licenciement que des mauvaises
nouvelles en espagne je enfin ouvrons
les yeux l'année 2012 risque d'être une
belle année par rapport à 2013
ouvrons les yeux chantal jouanno voilà
encore peut-être un cafouillage qui va
faire du bruit au sénat la proposition
de loi du parti socialiste sur les
tarifs progressifs de l'énergie a été
déclarée irrecevable lors de son examen
en commission les sénateurs de droite et
les communistes se sont unis pour
l'occasion ils craignent que ce texte
soit lourd de conséquences pour les
ménages explications faustine saint
genis
une victoire à l'arrachée pour les
communistes et leur motion
d'irrecevabilité voté à 20 voix contre
19 un désaveu au bonus malus énergétique
engagement de campagne de françois
hollande un vote incompréhensible pour
la ministre de l'énergie delphine batho
présentant commission c'est un texte
aussi qui permet d'étendre les tarifs
sociaux à 8 millions de français qui
sont confrontés à des situations de
précarité énergétique et cette
proposition de loi apporte une réponse
immédiate et c'est assez
incompréhensible que
des sénateurs communistes et pu voter
contre avec les voix de la droite
nouveau couac dans la majorité la motion
d'irrecevabilité met fin à l'examen du
texte par le sénat si elle est confirmée
en séance publique
une victoire pour les communistes il
énonce qu'une rupture du principe
d'égalité dans les tarifs de l'énergie
ce n'est pas une proposition la de loi
qui va vers la justice sociale elle elle
appliquera un malus à des gens
extrêmement défavorisés qui n'ont pas
les moyens de requalifier leur logement
elle est complexe elle est inapplicable
on a mis des cavaliers législatifs donc
à notre avis elle a beaucoup de défauts
c'est pour cela que nous avons donc
proposé cette motion qui est votée en
effet le texte prévoit une consommation
de base de gaz et d'électricité au delà
de ce seuil
le malus s'appliquera pour les ménages
les plus énergivores la motion
d'irrecevabilité sera présenté en séance
au sénat le 30 octobre prochain alors
chantal jouanno vous connaissez bien sûr
toutes ces questions vous avez été
ministre de l'écologie ce texte prévoit
un bonus malus aparté plutôt d'un bon
sentiment pour les consommateurs
pourquoi est ce que la droite et vous
même maintenant au centre vous n'en
voulez pas avec vous à nous ce qu'on
dénonce en tout cas lui dis c'est pas
l'objectif du texte c'est vraiment les
modalités parce que les modalités non
mais les modalités font que le
dispositif est extrêmement intrusif
faire valoir décortiquer et c'est
logique le mode de vie du ménage pour
pouvoir adapter la tarification
donc c'est vraiment sur les modalités
nous ce qu'on avait quand on en a
discuté d'ailleurs ce qu'on propose
c'est qui est vraiment une mission sur
le sujet parce que là c'est un peu
bricolé c'est tellement bricoler que le
rapporteur au sénat s'était dit je vais
tout réécrire je veux que ce soit pour
que ce soit acceptable de fait il a
démissionné
donc l'idée proposer vos textes l'idée
pas vrai je vous rappelle que ça reprend
quand même l'idée de la taxe carbone
quelque part même si c'est si c'est sûr
sur l'énergie mais mais pas avec effet
cette forme de précipitation qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui c'est trop bricoler mais
vraiment femmes
nous on a un problème de
de forme de modalités pratiques et on
dit qu'on veut faire une mission
d'information là dessus et proposer
quelque chose qui tienne un peu la route
est globalement très compliqué vous en
conviendrez on a vu cette semaine que le
conseil des arts touba les tarifs de
l'électricité de la rénover vers le
mondial il ya une vraie forme de
précipitation sur la plupart des projets
qui sont présentés celui là a été
attaqué hier son endroit hier soir on a
adopté une proposition doit de lui dit
sur le financement de l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie contre l'avis
du gouvernement
je rappelle que le traité passé quand
même avec les voix de la droite donc on
voit bien qu'il ya un vrai problème
aujourd'hui entre le gouvernement et sa
majorité au parlement
je vois mais cette alliance avec les
communistes est nouveau ça c'est pas le
sujet d'une alliance avec les
communistes on a voté contre
chacun a voté contre pour des raisons
différentes donc c'est pas ça vous fait
césar c'est une première mais qui
pourrait peut-être un armistice est pas
une c'est pas en raison on est on est
chacun dans notre rôle et on n'est pas
du tout dans une fonction de fond chacun
à une opposition fondée sur une raison
différente
ça a été très bien expliqué bon alors
c'est l'occasion justement de parler un
petit peu de la situation au sénat le
gouvernement est donc mis en difficulté
sur cette proposition de loi
peut-être aussi on verra sur les
recettes du budget quand ça viendra au
sénat
on pensait que les difficultés viendrait
surtout des écologistes mais finalement
c'est le front de gauche les communistes
qui donne du fil à retordre alors quelle
majorité au sénat
c'est un sujet de jérôme rabier la
courte majorité au sénat va si l
approche du vote sur le projet de loi de
finances 2013 avec seulement six voix
d'avancé pour la gauche le ps aura
besoin de tous ses alliés radicaux verts
mais aussi communiste pourtant au moment
de la présentation du projet de budget
en septembre dernier pierre laurent
affiche et déjà son hostilité
qu'on ne nous dise pas que ce budget est
parc neuf salariés sur 10
parce que d'une part le gel du barème de
l'impôt sur le revenu va toucher un très
grand nombre de salariés et pas
seulement parmi les plus aisés le groupe
communiste entretient le suspense
jusqu'à mardi prochain pour savoir
quelle position à 2
et chez les verts qui n'ont pourtant pas
voter le récent traité budgétaire
européen on appelle à plus d'unité il
faut le dire et je crois que c'est aussi
valable pour renault écologistes il faut
être capable aussi aux moments
importants de faire des efforts de crise
dans la majorité
chaque allié à ses exigences dernier
exemple avec le texte sur le logement le
gouvernement a dû se plier aux demandes
des radicaux de gauche pour qu'il soit
adopté une indépendance revendiquée par
le groupe
nous nous avons l'habitude de dire ce
que nous pensons très clairement nous
avons aussi l'habitude d'être loyaux par
rapport à nos alliés mais nous n'avons
pas à faire un marchandage quelconque
avec le gouvernement ou avec tel ou tel
autre groupe ce n'est pas notre
tradition des tractations qui sont
pourtant quotidienne au sénat entre le
ps et ses alliés
le risque étant que lassé par cette
courte majorité le gouvernement finisse
par ne compter que sur sa majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale pour
faire adopter ses textes
quand on entend ça chantal jouanno vous
devez être content d'avoir été élue
sénatrice parce qu'on sent que dans les
mois qui viennent c'est ce sera la
chambre de position à risque
bah ça risque vous avez au sénat en
général il peut y avoir il ya souvent et
c'est pour ça que j'aime bien le sénat
des consensus ou des compromis qui
dépasse très largement les clivages
politiques dès lors qu'on pense tout ce
qu'on va dans le bon sens il ya une
constance non il ya beaucoup de rapports
qu'on adopte à l'unanimité on est moins
dans les bus dans l'est dans les
magouilles politiques au sénat on est
moins dans les effets de manche et très
souvent il ya des textes d'ailleurs qui
sont beaucoup plus progressiste que ceux
qui sont adoptés à l'assemblée nationale
c'était le cas sur le grenelle c'était
cas sur la bioéthique et ce sera
probablement encore le cas sur quelques
textes qui vont qui vont venir mais je
suis justement justement quand on
bricole trop voilà quand on fait quand
on essaye de passer en force comme l'a
fait trop souvent le gouvernement
dernièrement et bah ça bloque au sénat
et ça bloque pour des raisons de fond
donc il va falloir arrêter mépriser le
sénat je sais que c'est une grande
tradition républicaine et mépriser le
sénat mais quand même va falloir arrêter
de mépriser et si j'ai travaillé dans le
bon sens selon vous le budget le projet
de loi sur la sécurité sociale
ça risque d'être retoqué au sénat parce
que les communistes vont s'abstenir là
aussi
vous dire quelles sont précisément les
votes des communistes je veux vous
redire en tout particulièrement sur le
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui a des dispositions
qui font bondir parce que quand on voit
les dispositions de la création sur les
emplois des aides à la personne sur les
auto-entrepreneurs certes tous qui crée
de l'emploi
on se dit mais on va vraiment pas dans
le bon sens et tout ça pour des postures
très politique
les centristes ont voté notamment sur
les emplois d'avenir que ce soit
l'assemblée au sénat
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres textes sur
lequel vous seriez prêt à apporter vos
voix au gouvernement aux balles et les
valets pas des centristes parler de lui
dit aujourd'hui la cellule dès
aujourd'hui la manière dont jean louis
borloo a voulu le positionner dimanche
et je veux insister là dessus c'est
vraiment le parti qui va être
progressiste qui va défricher de
nouvelles idées qui se positionne sur
l'économie tous on est tous ensemble
mais s'est lui dit voilà c'est lui des
lions du programme dépasse que très haut
on veut vraiment dépassé 7 cette image
qu'on a trop souvent d'un centre qui
seraient trop centre qui serait un peu
un peu entre deux chaises
non pas du tout on veut nos bureaux se
réinscrire dans la logique et de ses
moins de veille et de valéry giscard
d'estaing qui ont fait la renommée qu'on
légalise l ivg qui ont fait le droit de
vote à 18 ans donc que nous c'est
l'écologie c'est l'europe fédérale c'est
le libéralisme sur les questions de
société même sur les questions les
questions économiques donc on est ce que
vous êtes prêt à porter voilà je prie
j'avais envie de préciser ça me fait
plaisir que si ça va dans le bon sens il
n'y a pas de posture on essaye de
travailler dans le bon sens de l'intérêt
général parce que vraiment vraiment très
préoccupé par la situation de la france
et de l'europe à la france tout seul
c'est l'europe aujourd'hui notamment sur
le voilà deux étrangers on a demandé un
beau coup
au sein du au sein du groupe sur
personnellement j'ai toujours trouvé que
le principe de voter uniquement alors
que l'argument aujourd'hui c'est
simplement qu'on paye 10 ans pour alors
que c'est quand même le vote c'est c'est
l'adhésion impact de valeur la france l
adhésion impact de valeur c'est pas vous
n'êtes pas français puisque vous êtes né
ici ou parce que votre sang et de la
bonne couleur où vous avez la bonne
couleur de peau vous êtes français
puisque vous adhérer à des valeurs et
mais ça c'est via la nationalité ils
veulent revoir les conditions
d'accession à la nationalité donc
aujourd'hui
non non non je ne suis pas moi je ne
suis pas convaincu du tout par le droit
de vote des étrangers parce que c'est
vraiment présenté comme c'est pas
fondées politiquement voilà fondé
politiquement vous attendez encore un
petit peu avant de faire votre choix où
il ya du débat au sein du groupe
après on n'a pas le texte donc on peut
pas bâtir quelque chose alors on va
passer mercredi chantal jouanno tempête
en série pour le gouvernement bat la
série noire continue pour le
gouvernement cette fois 7 le conseil
constitutionnel qui sont sur un autre
texte phare le logement social mais ce
qui va déclencher les foudres de
l'opposition
c'est que le premier ministre va donner
l'information avant les sages et de
mémoire de constitutionnalistes on
n'avait jamais vu ça
j'arrive queyras car pardon et jérémy
hartmann c'est la déclaration qui a mis
le feu aux poudres ce matin sur une
radio du service public
jean marc guiraud court circuite le
conseil constitutionnel et annonce la
censure de la loi sur le logement social
il ya eu un cafouillage parlementaire je
le regrette mais en ce qui concerne la
cause de cette annulation
vous savez que le conseil
constitutionnel a été saisi sur un
problème de forme de procédure par l'ump
bon l ump a obtenu l'annulation très
bien pour l'ump mais c'est pas bien pour
les français
du pain béni pour la droite qui s'empare
du sujet cet après midi dans l'hémicycle
que s'est il passé à la suite de ce qui
est bien plus qu'une négligence de
procédures de ski et le fait de bafouer
les droits du parlement
vous nous annoncez curieusement vous
fait le porte parole du conseil
concessions
el houdoud annonçait que le texte fera
sans curé jean marc ayrault monte au
front et donne des gages de respect de
l'ordre constitutionnel
si vous êtes inquiet ne vous n'allez pas
m'apprendre que je connais parfaitement
les principes de la séparation des
pouvoirs et que j'ai trop de respect
pour cette séparation des pouvoirs ainsi
que pour la totale indépendance du
conseil constitutionnel pour qu'ils
aient la moindre ambiguïté mais salle
des quatre colonnes
l'opposition ne semble pas très
convaincu tous les jours on a une
nouvelle preuve de l'amateurisme de ce
gouvernement le premier ministre
il ya une semaine nous explique que
c'est fini les couacs de ses ministres
c'est fini les cafouillages et ce matin
c'est lui qui fait un quad
c'est lui qui a fait je sais pas ce qui
se passe à matignon mais il ya besoin de
sérénité
et puis à peut-être besoin aussi que le
président de la république donne un cap
tout simplement
à 18h le conseil constitutionnel
confirme enfin sa décision d'annuler la
loi sur le logement social
motif la procédure parlementaire n'a pas
été scrupuleusement respectée la gaffe
de jean marc ayrault a presque éclipsé
l'essentiel un des principaux textes
législatifs du gouvernement va prendre
un sérieux retard
chantal jouanno on va parler du texte
dans une seconde mais d'abord je
voudrais vous entendre sur jean marc
ayrault il se dit victime de chronique
quotidienne de démolition il ya de
l'acharnement sont jean-marc ayrault
marqué les sympathiques pas ce qui les
alimente tout seul je veux dire qu'on
n'a pas besoin de se forcer
effectivement pour pouvoir dénoncer les
difficultés les quoique les amateurisme
c'est assez étonnant c c'est assez
étonnant c'est du jamais vu
politiquement ça a été rappelé je
comprends mal qu'après autant de temps
de préparation théoriquement il soit
dans une telle un préparation à
l'exercice du pouvoir donc sur le fait
qu'ils aient bafouer les droits du
parlement
pardon mais on les avait prévenus et il
ya des procédures c'est pas une question
de forme
c'est vraiment une question de fond on
est prêt dans la toute puissance et un
exécutif qui est piloté uniquement par
le parti socialiste on n'est pas dans la
toute puissance ou qu'on comprenne bien
ce que le conseil constitutionnel a
souligné c'est là dessus que le texte
était retoqué
c'est que le texte que vous avez
examiner était ce le projet du
gouvernement est pas la version amendée
voilà ça alors ils sont là ils sont
passés en force et ils nous ont
suffisamment dénoncé attaquer quand deux
temps en temps on utilisait la procédure
d'urgence qui était rarissime pour
qu'aujourd'hui on leur rappelle qu'il ya
une procédure qui est un parlement qu'il
faut le respecter alors tout
particulièrement au sénat tout
particulièrement où ils sont dans une
grande fragilité mais vraiment c'est
sait on peut pas faire on veut
l'exercice du pouvoir
ça n'est pas l'exercice de la politique
du parti socialiste cette fronde a des
parties du sénat vous l'avez rappelé
écouter quelques réactions notamment
dans l'opposition il n'y a pas de
cafouillage parlementaire il y à un
cafouillage gouvernemental
il ya un cafouillage à une impréparation
du côté du gouvernement
une précipitation peut-être
dû au fait qu'ils avaient avancé la date
de la session extraordinaire mais la
responsabilité si tenté qu'il y ait une
annulation tout à l'heure c'est la seule
responsabilité du gouvernement
le parlement a fait son travail que le
gouvernement fasse le sien je crois
pouvoir le dire sous la vème république
c'est du jamais vu au moins jean marc
ayrault restera dans les mémoires comme
le seul premier ministre à avoir réussi
à bafouer le parlement et le conseil
constitutionnel dans la même matinée la
performance mérite d'être relevé bon
c'est vraiment la levée de boucliers a
même vu dans la presse libération
journal qualifié de gauche qui a titré
les apprentis jean marc ayrault votre
l'asie va tenir si on est en situation
idyllique sur le plan économique social
sent une montée des extrêmes extrêmement
préoccupante à la limite cet amateurisme
serait grave mais pas catastrophique
mais là aujourd'hui je trouve qu'on n'a
pas le droit comme ça d'être d'être dans
une telle impréparation et autant autant
amateur vraiment et surtout enfin le
texte est arrivé dans une précipitation
à tel point que le rapporteur a été
capable de faire un rapport
dans la minute qui a suivi l'audition du
ministre quand même est extraordinaire
il est capable de faire un rapport avant
même d'avoir entendu ministre donc un
rapport qui a été quand même écrit dans
les cabinets ministériels
c'est pas du tout du tout comme ça qu'on
peut travailler correctement surtout
dans un domaine qui est celui du
logement dont on sait très bien qu'il
faut ensuite des mois pour que ça a un
impact concret sur le terrain donc il
n'était pas obligé de précipiter autant
la procédure bon on va passer au jeudi
et on va parler plfss c'est à
l'assemblée
alors plfss bien sûr projet de loi de
finances de la sécurité sociale le texte
est examiné dans l'hémicycle cette
semaine et en ce jeudi les députés cible
pêle mêle les retraités le tabac la
bière explications de rym ben ameur
c'est oui pour la taxe sur la bière mais
les petites brasseries indépendante ne
seront pas concernés
de nombreux députés de droite comme de
gauche avaient pourtant bataillé tout
l'après midi contre cette taxe derrière
la bannière de jean pierre decool qui
mène la fronde depuis des semaines je ne
résiste pas en tant qu'homme du nord à
cité général de gaulle qui disait
lorsque l'on presse
les états-majors de faire des économies
il faut empêcher de les faire sur les
haricots du soldat parce que la bière
est aussi un élément de culture
populaire c'est oui aussi pour la hausse
du prix du tabac + 40 centimes par
paquet dès juillet un texte adopté sans
trop d'opposition
excepté cette passe d'armes sur le
cannabis cela est assez étrange
d'entendre d'une part un discours de
prévention contre le tabagisme et
d'autre part d'entendre que l'on propose
c'est qu'on a entendu dans la bouche
d'un certain nombre d'élus de la
majorité et avec un prolongement dans
les propos ministériels d'au moins deux
membres du gouvernement qu'il faudrait
aller vers une dépénalisation du
cannabis
si vous avez bien entendu ce que ce qu'a
dit un de vos collègues tout à l'heure
puisque vous parlez de débordements
ministériel il y là d'une chose très
intéressante mais on sort servira
éventuellement le moment venu la
prohibition ne sert à rien quelques
heures plus tôt une autre taxe très
contestée été votée celle sur les
retraites
un prélèvement de 0,3 pour cent qui
touchera 7 million et demi de personnes
la taxe sur les retraites donc 0 3% à
partir du 1er avril il fallait quand
même taxer les retraités qui par rapport
aux actifs pour l'instant le sont moins
ce qui alors nous ce qu'on a proposé à
ali dsk est adoptée au sénat hier soir
c'est qu'il y ait une taxe de 0 3% alors
sous conditions de ressources c'est à
dire que vraiment les petites retraites
ne sont pas touchés ce qui est pour
financer
l'apa l'allocation personnalisée
d'autonomie parce qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une impasse financière énorme dans les
départements sur ce sujet donc voilà ce
qu'on a proposé hier soir il n'y a pas
de raison si un retraité a le même nîmes
au niveau de vie qu'un actif qui
participe pas globalement à la
solidarité nationale pour autant
aujourd'hui globalement dans ce qui est
assez préoccupant sur le plfss dans son
ensemble c'est que la cour des comptes
nous dit très bien dans tous ces
rapports je rappelle toujours présidé
par monsieur migaud ça n'a pas changé
que l'essentiel de l'effort doit être
d'abord sur la maîtrise des dépenses et
qu'ensuite on recherche des recettes
supplémentaires il n'y a aucun effort de
maîtrise des dépenses ton père fss aucun
donc tous portent sur la quête de
recettes supplémentaires et kiener ou et
puis ne vont pas ou et ça c'est assez
anecdotique la réalité c'est quand même
ça ça ça va toucher tout le monde
mais vraiment tout le monde c'est pas
les plus riches ça va toucher tout le
monde est vraiment moi sur les emplois à
domicile concret et ça a été le premier
créateur d'emplois et c'est pas les
riches c'est tout le monde ça a été le
premier créateur d'emplois ce qui est en
train de se passer ça les auto
entrepreneurs est assez est assez grave
sur la bière je vais être très honnête
avec vous moi je suis favorable et je
vais vous dire j'ai un conflit
d'intérêts parce que mon mari travaille
dans une grande entreprise d'alcool de
france une très grande donc sur moi j'ai
toujours considéré qu'il fallait taxer
l'alcool au premier degré avec une taxe
exponentielle parce que toutes les
addictions ou tabac ou drogue toutes les
addictions sont des fléaux pour notre
société
bon mais ça c'est et l'écologiste et la
sportif qui vous parle des soirées
devait animer à la maison sur le sur le
tabac c'est bon ça c'est dans la droite
ligne de ce qu'a fait le précédent
gouvernement ce qu'on veut c'est dans la
droite ligne on sait vous et moi que
pour que ç'a un impact sanitaire réel
il faut une augmentation substantielle
d'un coup du prix du tabac pour que
réellement sa une un impact sanitaire
réel et là aussi c'est encore la droite
qui le dit mais j'aimerais bien vous
entendre là dessus c'est le pouvoir
d'achat de tous les français qui est
touchée que ce soit ne tabac que ce soit
la bière que ce soit d'autres taxes qui
sont en vente au tabac jeudi du délit
hier ce sont ce sont des fléaux parce
qu'on le paye très cher dans sa vie et
on le paye très cher quand on quand on
vieillit tout est une question
d'équilibré
voilà l'alcool c'est possible mais il
faut pas en consommer en consommer de
deux trous donc tout ce qui est quand
c'est du pouvoir d'achat entre
guillemets choisi ce que l'alcool ou la
drogue
enfin pas la drogue par dont le tabac
c'est une forme de drogue dans mon
esprit mais l'alcool ou le tabac c'est
malheureusement une addiction choisit
alors on à dire du mal un sondé faire
mais ça n'est pas le cas des produits de
première nécessité ce n'est pas des le
cas effectivement des autres taxes
le plus grave dans ce plfss à mon avis
c'est pas les taxes qui pèsent sur la
consommation ce sont toutes les taxes
qui pèsent sur le travail est vraiment
je vous le dis les emplois à domicile
c'est une catastrophe pour l'emploi en
france
donc le travail là on tue le travail
c'est ce que vous voulez dire mes yeux
il faut moi ma logique elle a toujours
été là même gelé défendu sur la taxe
carbone réduire toutes les taxes et
cotisations qui pèsent sur le travail et
les basculer sur les colos enfin les la
pollution et la consommation parce
qu'ils aient une vraie interrogation
aussi sur l'hyper consommation à la
consommation de base l'hyperconsommation
alors chantal jouanno maintenant on en
vient à votre ancien parti l'ump vous
savez que jeudi soir il y avait un grand
débat entre jean françois copé et
françois fillon vous allez nous dire
dans un instant si vous l'avez regardé
et bien l'objectif tout simplement été
d'éviter tout dérapage qui a eu lieu
résultat pas d' attaque mais quelques
différences entre les deux candidats le
tout dans une ambiance plutôt policé
comme nous l'expliquent germain andrieu
c'était un duel très attendu mais le
combat a été très feutrée et surtout
sans accroc une quinzaine de minutes
chaque jean françois copé face à
françois fillon
ils sont presque face à face mais aucune
opposition frontale
la confrontation est immédiatement
désamorcer j'ai pas d'adversaire dans
cette campagne il ya une compétition et
vous n'avez jamais entendu depuis le
début de cette campagne dans ma bouche
la moindre formule qui puisse être
désagréable à l'égard de jean françois
ou mêmes choses françois très bien dit
les choses il y a entre françois et moi
un respect total
on a effectivement des différences mais
on a surtout beaucoup de points communs
et cette horreur de la même famille
reste de cette image inédite pour la
droite l'ancien premier ministre
face à l'actuel secrétaire général de
l'ump des différences à la marge mais
surtout des valeurs communes comme leur
opposition de la au mariage homosexuel
mettrait tout ce que je peux de
conviction pour convaincre que cette loi
va faire vraiment terriblement de
déstabilisation dans la société
je suis un républicain qui respectent la
loi même si ça me poserait un certain
nombre de vrais problèmes de conscience
donc c'est 23 en revanche en revanche je
dis tout de suite que ce n'est pas un
texte sur lequel je considère qu'il ne
faudrait pas revenir lorsqu'il y aura
une alternance prasow militants jean
françois copé a su son positionnement
plus à droite françois fillon lui en
profite pour clarifier sa stratégie
électorale qu en cas de duel entre le
parti socialiste et le front national
on ne peut pas demander aux électeurs de
l'ump de voter pour un parti socialiste
qui est en train de conduire le pays
dans le mur ça c'est pas possible
et donc je n'appellerai jamais à voter
pour le parti socialiste en tout cas en
l'état
de la gauche et du parti socialiste
français il y à une droite complexé il
ya une droite qui est dans la fausse
pudeur mon positionnement c'est celui
que je que je dis bien souvent d'une
droite décomplexée c'est à dire d'une
droite qui s'assume seul face à face de
la campagne les 266 1000 militants
encore trois semaines pour faire leur
choix
mais quel que soit le vainqueur le 18
novembre la compétition il ne sera pas
terminé derrière l'unité affichée
les primaires à l'ump sont déjà
programmée pour 2016
alors maintenant que vous êtes à lui d y
est ce que vous avez regardé ce débat
oui bien sûr que j'ai regardé ce débat
c'est quand même un grand moment de la
politique c'est le aujourd'hui à ce
qu'il en sera demain mais aujourd'hui
c'est le premier parti toi tu as gagné
je n'ai pas à me prononcer là-dessus
pardon mais je suis suis sortie de deux
de l'ump donc je ne vais pas par
l'extérieur hors d'usagé pas dire
jusqu'à dire qui a gagné parce que je
suis sorti et j'ai eu l'honnêteté de le
faire en disant que c'est parce que je
voulais pas être justement une qui ne
voient désagréable interne
donc c'est pas pour le faire de
l'extérieur dans votre quartier tout
neuf du côté de françois fillon mais je
suis devenu très neutre pour une raison
très simple je suis venu à la politique
pour mes idées je suis venu à la
politique pour l'écologie c'est vraiment
mon combat c'est cesser mon combat
politique soutient françois fillon
semblait être aussi impartial ni l'un ni
l'autre préférence ni l'un ni l'autre
n'ont repris ce sujet aucun voilà aucun
donc aujourd'hui effectivement moi
j'avais pris du recul vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis des deux il a d'ailleurs
j'aime pas et c'est pas nécessairement
comme un soutien ni de l'un ni de
l'autre
j'ai de l'amitié pour françois fillon il
est effectivement plus rassembleur
jean-françois copé est quelqu'un qui
incarne un vrai dynamisme et qui a
vraiment bien organisés les dernières
campagnes électorales donc permettez
maintenant que je suis sortie de l'ump
ne surtout pas dire voilà c'est pas mon
rôle ne sait pas on ne demande pas un
responsable du parti socialiste de dire
qui a gagné entre les deux je suis pas
au parti socialiste mais je suis à lui
dis donc je trouve que ce serait pas
correct je posais la question
différemment vous allez
donnez votre réponse mais est ce que
vous avez senti chez l'un comme chez
l'autre
un bilan et une envie de revenir au
bilan de nicolas sarkozy a les deux s'y
sont refusées peut-être un peu plus jean
françois copé les deux françois pinault
les deux les 2,6 on s'y sont refusés à
toute façon nicolas sarkozy restera et
reste unique
nicolas sarkozy c'est quand même la
seule personne et c'est pour ça que moi
j'aimais le projet de 2007 c'était un
projet qui avait deux pieds très fort on
parler d'immigration choisie m'ont parlé
de discrimination positive
on parlait de la lutte contre l'islam
des caves mais on a créé le culte le
conseil français du culte musulman et on
a relancé aussi l'idée qu'il fallait
mieux avoir des mosquées donc moi je
vois la sportive si nicolas sarkozy
revient vous repartez à l'ump la
question se pose pas a priori puisque
pour l'instant il reste il l'a dit en
dehors de là on a plus de face mais je
fais au reste très moi je reste très
attaché à ses idées de 2007
aujourd'hui jean louis borloo portent
tous ces sujets d'ouverture de 2007
donc il est plus cohérent que je sois en
positif avec lui quand négatif à une
façon assez surprenante françois
françois fillon et exigeant soit fillon
a pris un peu de recul on a vu face à
face à nicolas sarkozy sur notamment les
annonces retardé pour psa
ça vous a surpris ça ou vous sentiez
déjà quand vous étiez vous ministre que
françois fillon de temps en temps avec
quand même de sérieux points
d'achoppement avec nicolas sarkozy mais
il ya forcément des débats entre enfin
voila il du débat politique on cherche
toujours la meilleure des la meilleure
des solutions aux comptes est cette
annonce alors je sais pas si elle a été
mal compris ou c'est un peu étonnant
enfin bon
que les grands patrons s'ils ont des
plans ne souhaite pas être
instrumentalisée dans le cadre d'une
campagne ça c'était vigan batterie la
face vous êtes dans le cadre d'une
campagne vous commencez à dire que vous
allez faire un plan social est à peu
près sûr d'être instrumentalisés de tout
de tout point de vue donc ça c'est
évident qu ensuite un grand patron
puisse se dire bon moi je vire tasser un
peu étonnant mais voilà j'ai pas les
tenants et les aboutissants de cette
affaire j'étais pas dans la confidence
on n'aura pas réussi à savoir entre
françois fillon et jean françois copé
mais on essaiera une prochaine fois
problème visiblement visiblement non
mais j'ai pas le faire c'est pas ce
serait pas loyal voilà je n'ai pas le
faire en tout cas quand on est extérieur
qu'on arrive le mieux juger oui vous
savez on considère souvent un peu trop
rigide tête de pioche et de clients j'ai
pas le faire tout cas merci merci
d'avoir répondu à toutes mes questions
merci on se retrouve après pour cause de
1er novembre et bon week-end à tous
temps